and hunter biden might not be the only
conflict of interest problem facing this
white house because in a new letter to
ron klaine being released exclusively on
this show tonight three gop congressmen
are requesting documents related to
attorney lee wololsky now wolosky was
hired last september to work with the
national security council on
resettlement and other issues regarding
the u.s drawdown from afghanistan he
resigned from his white house post in
january that's where things get
interesting
a month later biden issued an executive
order splitting 3.5 billion dollars in
assets from the afghan central bank
among the 9 11 victims
the attorney representing those families
you guessed it lee wolowski
joining us now is one of the co-signers
of that letter ohio congressman jim
jordan congressman
what do you hope to find in those
documents
well we hope to get some answers to a
couple questions we asked there but you
laid it out laura four months he gets
hired in september he leaves in january
a few days literally days after he
leaves we find out that his law firm
he's representing these plaintiffs who
get the windfall because joe biden
changed the process with an executive
order didn't go through the normal fund
you go through
for families who've been impacted and
hurt
by by terrorism so that that raises all
kinds of concerns and then you couple
that with what we're now learning about
the hunter biden situation which seems
to be all kinds of things get done that
benefit the first family that's our
concern and why we sent the letter
one of the lawyers congressman is
defending that huge amount of and legal
fees that they're set to receive
another havelish lawyer who is asked not
to be named dismissed the criticism that
their potential windfall is unfair 20
years ago everybody thought we were
crazy when we filed this lawsuit
when you're a success you're greedy
lawyers you said
well you're responsible lawyers do get a
lot of money congressman i mean as a
former practicing attorney you know if
it's 800 a thousand dollars an hour i
don't know what they charge or how they
how they calculated it it's a lot of
money
yeah they they do but this happened
literally days after he leaves the white
house where he was working on matters
that pertain to afghanistan he leaves
and the money that comes from
afghanistan goes around the normal
process into a new fund that is going to
benefit the very clients that he's
representing just days after he leaves
the white house so again this is the
same white house that told us on sunday
oh there's nothing to worry about uh
hunter biden and joe biden did nothing
wrong according to ron claim the same
ron claim who you just talked about who
10 years ago was going to hunter biden
said hey can you give us some money to
help the vice president and keep it low
low key so i think that's a concern
when you have particularly these two
events happening at the same time we're
learning all kinds of information
relative to the first family well
congressman when you hear joe biden say
as we just played
um a few minutes ago when he said oh
well the justice department
they they have to act independently i
know i'm not putting any pressure but
then they clearly managed to leak out
the fact that the president of the
united states wants
the
merrick garland attorney general to act
more like a prosecutor and less like a
ponderous judge so they knew that was
coming out that it in and of itself
could pressure garland yes
yeah they want him to go after president
trump and also just think about how this
hunter biden story has changed first it
was it wasn't hunter biden's laptop then
it was oh it's his laptop but it's
russian disinformation and then it was
well it's not really russian
disinformation but joe biden wasn't
involved now was well joe biden was
involved but they did nothing wrong
because ron klain told us on sunday they
did nothing wrong i mean that is amazing
how that is that how that has evolved
over 18 months it went from 18 months
ago no though no this is not true to now
we had the washington post last
wednesday write two stories one at 11
o'clock one at 1104. two eight page
stories four minutes apart saying it's
all true the laptop is real the
eyewitness is real the emails are real
the only thing fake 18 months ago was
the news and it was just days before the
most important election we had in the
american people were denied an
opportunity to have the facts in front
of them when when they make a decision
about who's going to be our
commander-in-chief that's why this is so
important and then you couple it with
this story with how this one lawyer
benefited just days after he left the
white house
that that is that is why so many
americans are so frustrated by what they
see going on in today's white house and
the biden administration well it's nice
that the washington post says that you
know it's time for a reckoning over the
hunter biden story yep but you know it's
it's kind of late i mean congressman
we'll find out we'll find out eventually
the truth i appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else